these kids back here have no idea what's
about to happen I'm about to give them a
hundred dollars in cash one hour to
spend it if they don't spend it in an
hour they don't get anything let's go
surprise them come on I have a challenge
for you if you think you're up to it
yeah what is that you have one hour to
spend $100 I got an hour if you don't
spend all the money in the hour you
don't get to keep anything you bought
what do you think you're gonna do what's
your plan of attack maybe give it to
people let's go let's find that ice
cream what are you gonna get stuff for
my room and stuff for school where you
want to go you have to make a decision
yeah all right
you a candy bar first ready the timer
starts now let's go y'all ride boy cold
treasure pets it comes like this move
skeleton guy you have to be able to
spend it all in our all of it all of it
let's get it before it goes away we made
100 put it in here and like $13 we'll go
to the toy store first Oh be careful
[Music]
bring down yeah but you can just so you
know times ticking we're here 40 minutes
left to spend the money you only spent
for the dollars what are you gonna get
Owen I'm looking for that's in minecraft
you like that it's a little TT look look
it's hilarious mug like it's a gold and
like a weird idea see is there anything
else you want no if I were kid I be
grabbing everything I see it's Owens
very particular you really want this one
story all right totally still got some
change back together steal his candy bar
[Music]
anything seeing good back you can't get
stuck here what do you like you're
getting a lot of different stuff
don't be scared of a brain freeze you
got to eat so fast right cuz we gotta
get to spend that money what are you
gonna do with your money now I'm gonna
put it in the bank that's you don't want
to get toys you want to put it in the
bank
let's do it that's money thing are those
pigeon yeah they're a bunch of pigeons
oh come on
don't get distracted alright so we're
gonna walk through the farmers market
I'm getting corn it says five for two
dollars
it's the stuff I don't wanna eat too
much corn maybe flour he was you want
this one
mom spend this money I'm buying it for
some lawyer
oh you're buying if there's someone yep
that's nice of you it's for me oh my god
that's so sweet
four dollars we're really stunning
that's money
target now so it's for you're gonna have
to pay for the cab that's you're willing
to do it to get to that toy yeah all
right let's do it let's hail a cab wife
how much do you think you're gonna spend
a target you know what I think we should
see how much all the stuff is let's make
sure you got you can get it all right
put over a candy our life I got and some
random stuff I want cotton candy please
uh cotton candy gets made
while others definitely jealous
I'm gonna be the coolest kid in school
this is kind of like the crazy
accomplice
I'm going to pay you by dollars how much
how much money is here I'll give you
your five dollars for it all right give
you a little more I know it sounds
really expensive but I gave a lot money
away itself I truly don't want to spend
it out honey wait a second
Sal what here's a bank do you want to
stop in did you want to stop for your
money in now tiles
do you guys know buying these whales
[Music]
yeah
x marks the spot do you want to pick out
some more stuff together
[Applause]
what do you guys want unicorns what do
you like you like unicorns should I grab
one oh good all right there's one thing
that suddenly that's ten bucks you got a
lot more you can get you only have a
certain amount Tory found it found that
something you want that's smart
that's my replace broken things I'm not
getting a costume until Halloween I feel
like I want to costume and you want
ammonia yeah I run a bull nail whoa just
think think think
we just went to Dylan's Candy Bar where
are we going next yeah dresses you have
ten minutes do you think you can do it
how much money it left four dollars okay
I have one little doll laughs what are
you gonna spend it on something in the
toy store
hold that for now let's go
do you know where your sizes yeah okay
more money laughs how much more you need
I have one left
yeah give me one more dollar left
nothing wrong you need nine more sense
but we all have mine with that what are
you guys gonna do one minute left
and you have to spend $4 and some amount
of change how do you think you're gonna
do it
so love you'll give it to someone okay
here we go I I have a hobo in my
backpack
we do need your doing that for your
brother
[Music]
four dollars
I want you work together to solve this
do you think you spent your hundred
dollars wisely
not really I got a hundred dollars and I
spent it good what made you give that
woman the four dollars at the end feel
good what felt better helping your
brother are getting all the toys working
together I won the challenge
[Music]